I'm on a one day break from touring with
Jordan Peterson and joining me in studio
today is a free speech lawyer and the
director of the Individual Rights
Defense Program at the foundation for
Individual Rights in education,
Aka fire red called welcome to the Rubin
report.
Thanks for having me.
That was a wordy interest right there.
A lot of freedom stuff in there and that
that's all the stuff that I like.
So I'm looking forward to this same.
So you guys fire as an organization is
one of the few bastions of sanity these
days.
Like when I see what you guys are
tweeting about and consistently
defending the principles of free speech
and free expression and open inquiry,
I'm always like,
ah,
there are some good guys left.
So first can you just tell me a little
bit about the organization,
why you guys got started and how you
personally got involved?
Well,
we got started in 1999 with a professor
at Penn and a civil liberties lawyer in
Philadelphia who were,
you know,
they both decided that there were,
uh,
there was a problem.
There was an epidemic at our colleges.
And Universities of the core individual
rights that,
that make up,
you know,
our,
our constitution,
if you will,
um,
as individuals,
as people,
as citizens of the United States,
uh,
Brent being respected on campuses across
the country
back in [inaudible] 99.
Did nine.
Yeah,
that's interesting because a lot of
people say this is just the totally
recent phenomenon.
I think,
uh,
you know,
a lot of it that there is the political
correctness movement to the eighties and
nineties,
a little bit,
you know,
that might've had something to do with
it,
but this has been a problem since the
free speech movement back at Berkeley.
Uh,
you know,
long before even the eighties or
nineties,
you know,
censorship is an age old problem that
predates the United States of America.
Really.
Uh,
and as Alan and harvey went about
creating fire and they decided to locate
it and like located in Philadelphia,
which is the birthplace of our nation,
they really got an outpouring of people
saying,
Hey,
this happened to me too.
Uh,
and they said,
well,
this is,
you know,
this is a problem.
This is an epidemic.
We need to fix it and fire was born,
um,
or,
or lit,
if you will.
And uh,
over the years getting close to 20 now,
crazy enough,
uh,
that has actually just gone up every
year more and more people reach out to
fire for help.
When I got to fire for the second time,
I actually was a legal fellow with fire
after I graduated from law school before
I started in private practice,
uh,
but when I came back in 2013 getting
several hundred case submissions a year,
um,
and now we are getting damn near close
to a thousand a year,
a credible.
And that's just the stuff that we hear
about.
I can only imagine how much other stuff
is going on around the country for
people who don't know that we're out
there to them,
uh,
or you know,
people who perhaps go about it
themselves.
It's,
it's crazy to think about how much is
going on.
Yeah.
So I want to talk about some of those
cases and some of the specific work that
you're doing,
but foundation for individual rights in
education.
I am a believer right now partly because
of Kanye West and because of a lot of
people online right now that the
individual is making a comeback that the
idea of the individual versus the
collective is actually making a
comeback.
Do you have any idea when they came up
with a name for firewire was so
important to put the individual front
and center?
I think it's,
you know,
and I'm speaking out of some level of
ignorance because I haven't actually
discussed this with either of them
personally,
but you know,
if I had to guess,
it's because the individual qualities,
the freedom of conscious,
the freedom of speech for things that
allow us to participate in society.
We don't get to the collective unless we
have the individuals.
One is necessary to have the other
because what is a collective other than
a group of individuals and consensus is
a bunch of individual opinions.
That throughout the process of winnowing
and debating different good ideas and
bad ideas,
we reach a common understanding.
We reach a a,
you know,
a norm for society and that's how.
That's why free speech particularly is
so important is because that's how we
get to the optimal resolution,
the optimal conclusions,
that's how we reach these communal
positions is only through our own
personal expressions of what we believe,
which exposes us to criticism or
agreements or just flat out discussion
with other people.
So how do you think the ideas of the
collective took root so much a college
campus then?
Well,
I think there's the given take in
society at large that we really go
through every once in a while in terms
of thinking about things as
individualistic and then worrying about
broader concerns of the community and
it's not altogether a bad thing and I
think the college campus,
and it's always been this way,
it's a microcosm of what we're
experiencing in the broader society and
I think that's another reason why it's
so important to protect individual
rights on college campuses because where
they fall on college campuses,
they are almost certainly short to fall
in society writ large.
Yeah.
So that actually we discussed this
briefly right before the cameras turned
on.
That's my concern about this.
When people say,
Oh,
you know,
there isn't a free speech issue on
college campuses and even though I keep
going to college campuses and it's very
clear to me that there is a free speech
problem there,
but it's not what's going to happen.
It's not just the screaming kids right
now.
It's not that.
It's that these are the people that are
going to be in leader positions five,
10,
15 years in the future and further than
that obviously.
And if those ideas take root because
they were able to silence us once they
are the lawmakers,
once they're in charge of public policy,
they're not going to be too kind to the
people who they were silencing way back
when.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean that's really one of the key
problems and it's not even just if they
get elected to power,
even if they aren't elected,
uh,
and they don't rise to power and they
can impose these views on other people.
These are future citizens,
even if they're not necessarily future
leaders.
And then discourse of the nation,
if that is the,
the prevalent feeling in society is
going to suffer tremendously as a result
if even if they're not in Congress or in
the state legislatures,
if 50 percent of the country's
population thinks that we shouldn't be
talking about certain things,
we're not going to talk about these
things and it's going to be a societal
he imposed if nothing else.
And I think that's incredibly damaging
to just about every aspect of our life
is as a country.
Yeah.
It's so interesting to me because I know
you,
you read about this,
but I was at the University of New
Hampshire a couple of weeks ago and you
know,
first we were supposed to give a speech
on campus then about two hours before
they announced that they couldn't secure
the room,
that they felt there were too many
threats.
So they were about 200 or 250 people
supposed to be in the room.
They moved us to the hockey rink,
which seats 7,500
people.
So I stood in front of,
uh,
a little,
you know,
backdrop and I talked to about 200
people.
It was about 150 people that were there
to listen and be respectful and all that
stuff.
And then they were about probably about
50 protesters roughly.
Those are the rough numbers,
um,
but the desire just to shout down,
to use noisemakers to scream to chance
like robots,
they love robotic chance.
All of these things.
And I kept saying to them,
guys,
do you have any direct questions?
Is there something that I've said that
you disagree with or is there something
you directly like to ask me?
And time and time again,
the answer was no.
And I don't know how you break them out
of that other than keep having these
conversations and hope that the refugees
make it to us.
And that's a common problem.
I think it really comes down to
ideological purity that people are after
the idea that if I disagree with you on
something,
whether it's small or even fundamental,
if I disagree,
I disagree with you on that one thing.
That means nothing that you have to say
could possibly be a value to me and that
is completely false.
That you couldn't be farther from the
truth.
We can learn so much from the people we
disagree with the most.
Even if I disagreed with you on
absolutely everything.
It would still be incredibly valuable
for me to talk to you if only because
that helps me sharpen and really
understand why I believe what I believe
in and people really discount the
importance of understanding why you
believe something.
So the argument that I've been making
for awhile is that,
and I do think right now at least in
2018 and this is more of a problem on
the left,
that they've owned the ideas and the
narrative and the college campus
discussion and academia and media and
all that.
They've owned that for so long that the
reason these kids end up be are these
students ended up being so hysterical is
because they never hear a counter ideas.
So then you get a pretty moderate guy
who's arguing about liberty and freedom
for everybody and live and let live.
And that actually offends them.
Because they never hear anything outside
of what they're being taught.
That goes to the academic part.
I think mostly.
Well,
I think we're doing a really crappy job
of educating students before they get to
college about why free speech and our
other rights are important.
Civics education is clearly in the
toilet right now and it's bizarre to me.
I grew up in Skokie,
Illinois.
One of the sites,
one of the most famous free speech
cases,
you know,
in recent history.
Can you lay it out for those that don't
know this story.
In the seventies,
the American,
the American Socialist Party,
that Nationalist Party,
the Illinois Nazis,
if you'd asked the blues brothers wanted
to march through Skokie,
Illinois,
which outside of New York had the
largest concentration of Holocaust
survivors in the United States.
Uh,
and skokie tried to stop them and they
sued with the aid of the American Civil
Liberties Union of Illinois.
And it went to,
well,
both the Supreme Court of Illinois and
the Supreme Court in the United States.
Um,
and the Nazis had the right to March and
the courts held so and there were
threats of violence.
And disruption and all,
you know,
people out crying as to how this could
be allowed,
but ultimately the Nazis had the first
amendment right to march through skokie
and I grew up learning about that case
from a very young age.
I can't tell you how many times I saw
the movie they made about it and it
really.
It got me thinking at a young age about
why this is important,
how I think about it,
and I can't tell you that as a young
child,
I completely agree that the Nazis should
have a right to march when I was that
young,
I part of me didn't grasp the
overarching fundamental importance of
free speech,
but I was thinking about it.
It was just.
And I got there and I get the feeling
that sometimes we're not doing enough to
make our students think about why it's
important.
It's such an important case and I'm glad
you mentioned it because it goes really
to the heart of this,
that the people that lived in Skokie,
as you said,
the second largest amount of Holocaust
survivors in the country.
These people literally survived a
genocide.
Probably virtually all of them lost,
some of them probably lost all of their
family members and friends and all of
that.
And yet I would sit here at someone that
lost Holocaust survivors on both sides
of my family and tell you it was the
right decision.
You can't let the Nazis are the white
supremacists or whatever they are.
You can't let them start ransacking
property.
You can't let them start killing people
or harming people,
but letting,
letting them march at the exchange of
free speech and it's kind of Shitty,
but you got to defend when it's hard to
defend,
but you have to find it when it's hard
to defend because otherwise it's not
going to be around to defend when it's
easy to defend.
You know,
once you start creating exceptions and
encroaching,
there's no end to it.
And you know,
we've kind of seen even in other
countries,
uh,
that once the encroachments start,
it's always,
well,
we make that exception and just this one
other small exception.
And then there's inevitably another one
and another one and all for perhaps even
no good reasons in terms of,
you know,
ideals.
And the goals are laudable.
Perhaps I say it every show,
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and getting tired and you and
me both,
but you know,
it's really practically speaking,
it's inevitable.
Yeah.
How much of this is just a confusion as
to what the First Amendment is.
That's also what I've started to realize
because when I've gone on college
campuses and the protesters are there
and I always say it,
I welcome peaceful protest.
I completely welcome.
I welcome the exchange of ideas.
The question is all of that,
but when,
when they're screaming about certain
things,
I think there's just a disconnect as to
what I think to legal things.
I think what the First Amendment is and
what hate speech is,
is or isn't a.
So can you talk about that a little bit?
I,
if I had to have to hear one more
person,
whether it be student,
uh,
Internet comment or to even journalists
are faculty members sometimes say hate
speech is not free speech.
I'm going to lose it.
Okay.
So let's do,
let's do that one first because I
really,
I mean this will be maybe what we promo
for this episode,
but I really want people to understand
this.
Why is hate speech free speech?
Well,
on a legal level,
hate speech is free speech because the
First Amendment and the courts have said
nothing about freeze or hate speech
being unprotected by the first
amendment.
Speech is protected by the First
Amendment unless it falls under one of
the very few existing categories of
unprotected speech.
Yeah.
What are.
What are those categories?
There's incitement to imminent lawless
action and these all have very high
bars,
right?
True threats and intimidation.
A,
you can be sued for libel or slander.
Defamation is there.
No,
not some estates I think actually still
have criminal statutes on the book,
but books,
but they're rarely enforced of fraud.
Obscenity,
which people often confused with mere
profanity or lewdness,
but they are not the same thing by any
stretch of the imagination.
What?
What's the difference on those two?
Well,
profanity and lewdness or are generally
protected by the first amendment.
Obscenity is a very high bar.
It's speech that has to be our
expression,
I shouldn't say more broadly than just
speech that has to appeal to the puriant
interest,
which is an inordinate fascination with
sex,
describe or depict sex in a patently
offensive way and have no social
political,
literary or artistic value whatsoever
and to get down in the mud that.
Had you ever heard of crushed videos?
I feel like I have,
but I'm honestly not sure what that is.
They are videos of women wearing
stilettos crushing small animals like
hamsters and Gerbils to death and people
apparently get off on that.
I don't pretend to understand it.
Even that is not wholly unprotected by
the obscenity exception to the first
amendment that that's particularly
interesting case.
I suppose because the idea of it talking
about it seems like A.
I would have no problem with that,
but the action itself probably there's
some legal reasons,
right?
Like killing it,
killing animals.
There's some law I guess if trolley
state laws,
but if you have this pornography you can
call it that.
I just,
I have a hard time getting it.
If you have it in you to possess it or
you can't be prosecuted for,
for possessing that obscene material,
it's an interesting distinction that the
act is the crime or the act is what is
illegal,
not the depiction,
depiction or disseminating the
information or that sort of thing.
Right?
A child pornography,
obviously not protected by the first
amendment,
but there's.
Well,
there's the one additional wrinkle of
the fighting words doctrine,
although there's considerable doubt that
it remains a viable,
a exception to the first amendment,
but it really gets brought up a lot in
the hate speech debate to the extent it
still exists.
It's limited to face to face
interactions where say I say something
to you that is so insanely abusive that
you are likely to punch me in the face
without thinking twice about it.
Instead of taking a deep breath and
either ignoring me or coming back at me
and there's reasons why it's fallen into
disuse and it's worthwhile to note that
the Supreme Court has upheld a fighting
words,
convictions since the case in the
forties when it created the fighting
words except for.
It's interesting just how far it's
fallen into disuse.
It incentivizes punching people in the
face.
It creates an easy way to sensor the
people that you disagree with and it
would,
I assume be some level of a subjective
piece of information as to what you
think is offensive at the highest order
is different perhaps than what I think
exactly what some of these other people.
Yeah,
it it.
It creates terrible incentives and it
would basically lead to an
institutionalized heckler's veto,
so it's really not tenable.
Yeah,
so on the,
on the hate speech front,
which was clear what the Supreme Court
has said about hate speech,
you're allowed to do it with,
with these exceptions that you've just
laid out,
you're allowed to see me and things.
What I.
What I'm realizing on college campuses
is they really don't like that.
The people that set of people that we're
talking about,
they really don't like that.
So like they think if you like you,
it's just the fact you are allowed to
say bad things.
You can say,
I hate all the Jews.
I hate all the black people and all the
gays or whatever.
You can say it.
You can't cause direct call to violence,
but what I think they think is that if
you keep saying those things,
I hate these people,
that it's going to incite violence.
Now my counter argument would be,
no,
you have to use free speech to counter
those bad ideas.
That's the whole purpose of free speech.
But do you see that,
that,
that seems to be the slope that they
consistently are on,
that if we allow you to say,
I,
I hate these people,
which is bigoted and prejudice and all
those things,
but it's afforded to us by the bill of
rights.
They think that that's going to get you
to violence.
How do you combat that notion if you
agree with the premise that is something
that we tend to hear a lot in the first
amendment world.
Um,
and you know,
first of all,
generally speaking in this country,
we punish the people who do the bad
acts.
If I watch your show and I get some
cookie idea and go off and commit some
crime,
we're not going to throw you in jail
because I'm an idiot and took a terrible
idea that you didn't even intend me to
take right now.
That might be.
It might be different though if I was up
here saying you should violently attack
these people,
etc.
Etc.
Right.
Exactly.
That's why the incitement standard is so
high.
Yes.
To be likely to insight and intended to
incite immediate cRiminal action.
So if I tell you,
hey,
you know,
it'd be fun to burn down a building,
but you're not likely to do it.
You're going to take it as a joke.
I probably haven't committed any kind
of,
uh,
you know,
I'm awful expression if I know you're a
pyromaniac and I say,
hey dave,
let's go burn down a building.
Uh,
I might find mysElf in a very different
situation.
I sort of left that phase at about eight
years old.
But,
you know,
I think that if you take a look,
one of my colleagues actually wrote up a
piece for quill at a not so long ago
about the rwandan genocide and looking
over the claims that the radio
broadcasts actually caused more
violence.
And what it turns out is that the radio
broadcasts first of all,
only incited people who were already
predisposed and whoever you felt that
way and it made it marginally easier for
them to find people and you know,
be taught how to do certain things,
but it was relatively ineffective as it
turns out in convincing people who
weren't already in a murderous rage to
go out and commit violence.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
I think that the fear that allowing
these views to be aired is going to
indisputable,
he caused actual violence is somewhat
overblown.
Now there's a second part to it,
which is that people expressing these
views might lead to more people adopting
those views and having prejudice view.
Is that possible?
Absolutely.
RighT.
So that's the part I was referenced,
but that's kinda the point is that we
put those out there so we can fight
them.
If we don't have them in public and we
can't fight them,
they're still going to spread nothing.
No idea ever went away because we said
you can't say that.
It just doesn't work like that.
How does the heckler's veto fit into all
of this?
Because one of the things that I again
see on college campuses is when hecklers
starts screaming at you and then you
say,
just a second,
I'll get to your question or calm down,
or whatever you might say.
I'm.
They'll say,
well I have a right to free speech too.
They try to flip it on you to make you
look like a hypocrite.
That actually kinda kinda gets me,
but I will give them a little bit of
credit.
I think You say a university event and
somebody comes in and they chant for 30
seconds or they stand up and turn their
backs and that's the extent of it.
I Think that we should protect that
technically.
Are they causing a disruption?
Yes,
but it's minimal.
And it's actually maximized the amount
of free speech just to be some room for
very minimal disruption,
but when it gets to the point where they
are substantially interfering with the
speakers,
that ability to get their message across
or the audience's ability to hear them
through repeated shouting or noise
makers or standing in the front and
blocking everyone's views,
uh,
and things like that.
obviously that's a problem.
And last year we just saw a rash of a
heckler's vetoes going on and it kind of
all started with berkeley and milo
yiannopoulos when they protesters were
successful in shutting down the event
through what had been before that been
unfathomable on a college campus for an
invited speaker.
We've seen invited speaker controversy
since fire was founded.
Basically never ever am I aware of any
incident that came close to something
like that.
It was just madness.
Yeah.
And they got away with it.
The so few arrests were made.
And I can't help but wonder if the
students out at middlebury college where
Charles Murray was speaking,
sees done that and looked at the
berkeley students and said,
well,
they were successful in stopping that
event with speech that we also did
tested and they got away with it.
So let's try that.
it's a viable tactic.
This might be a solution for keepIng
this speech.
We disagree with off campus and ideas
like that,
that the tactics that students are able
to successfully utilized,
they will.
Behavior that is rewarded essentially is
going to be repeated.
Yeah.
And I see that all over the place right
now.
So for example,
just a couple of months after milo went
to berkeley and that happened,
a ben shapiro spoke,
they already was largely nonviolent,
but it cost the $600,000
to make that happen.
I mean,
I think an atm was broken in a couple of
windows and that's it.
But that's part of the tactic is if we
can keep ramping this up,
we'll keep pushing the security costs
and as I said,
they had to move my event to a freaking
hockey theater that a hockey arena that
couldn't have been cheap and and several
other.
These I saw,
I'm sure you're familiar with the case
of lindsay shepherd up at wilfrid
laurier from Canada and she just had to
crowdfund I think around six grand to
get security for one of her events.
So that almost seems like the new
tactic.
It's almost like we don't have to,
we can scare them with some threats of
violence and some other stuff and then
will cause the security costs to be so
high that you guys will just give up.
Well,
and that's another problem we've been
fighting since even before all of this
came to a head is colleges and
universities trying to charge student
groups security fees for the speakers
based on the anticipated protest or
controversy.
And that's plainly unconstitutional.
It has been for a long time since the
supreme court said that a listener's
reaction is not a content neutral basis
for regulation.
You cannot charge more for controversial
speakers because they might drop protest
that places have a price tag on
expression and prices,
like you said,
it will price the controversial
expression out of the marketplace.
They're not going to be able to afford
it.
What student group has $17,000
to spend on security,
none of them and you know what it comes
down to is administrators at the
university itself has to be the
guarantor of last resort when it comes
to speakers ability to speak and this is
the business they are in and sometimes
it's unpleasant and sometimes it costs a
whole lot of money,
but if you're not going to have a campus
where we can discuss things and we can
debate things,
even if it gets loud and boisterous and
raucous and contentious,
which is everything free speech should
be.
If your campus isn't going to be a place
where that occurs,
then what are you?
What are you doing?
So I do want to make a point of saying
that some of the campuses are getting it
right and I'm sure you know some of the
campuses that are doing a little better
than some of the others.
But for example,
uh,
at the beginning of September,
2017,
I spoke at claremont mckenna at,
they're doing a big free speech push
because of what happened the semester
before with Heather Mcdonald and all
hell broke loose and on the campus and I
was completely welcomed there and they,
even some of the students who disagreed
with me,
I mean they asked me questions and all
of that good stuff.
So it's where I alwaYs think it's worth
mentioning that some schools are doing
their best to manage some of this stuff.
Absolutely.
And on two levels,
I think,
you know,
first of all,
fire rates,
policies at schools,
we raised over 400 different colleges
and universities on a red light,
yellow light,
green light level,
a red light being,
you have policies that are clearly in
substantially unconstitutional yellow
light being.
You have policies that are susceptible
to being applied in bad ways and
greenlight schools where none of their
policies poses a serious threat to free
speech in the past couple of years.
The number of green light schools that
we have has nearly doubled,
which is tremendous.
Now,
still close to 60 percent of schools
have a yellow light,
so there's work to be done.
But you combine that with the 38 schools
that have now put out statements
expressly committing themselves to free
speech.
Uh,
something that,
you know,
the university of chicago kicked off a
while back.
There's reasons to be hopeful and we
work regularly with administrators who
are happy to have a consult on their
policies and say,
you know,
here are the changes we would make a.
And,
and we're,
we have amicable relationships with so
many administrators,
which is really gratifying.
But on the student side also,
part of it is overblown.
And I think by media there are a lot of
students out there who do get it and
people have all ideologies and all
political,
you know,
sides.
There are a lot of students out there
who get it.
I speak to them on a daily basis and I,
there is a lot of reason to have hope.
This is not a lost cause.
No,
I agree.
I think it's important talking about it
because even again at that university of
New Hampshire,
think 75 percent of the crowd at least
was there respectfully decently to hear
ideas and,
and do that what I felt was important
after and why I still want to talk about
and have you here and all that is
because I want people to be armed with
the right arguments so that when these
set of people,
even if it's just a smaller set that's
just really loud.
So as a disproportionate amount of
influence,
I want people to understand there are
tactics you can use to fight it.
So I'm curious on that list of 38
schools that's kind of doing it right
right now when they've instituted some
of these policies.
And I remember when university of
chicago did it about a year ago,
um,
is there evidence that things actually
get better?
Because I'm going to guess that when you
give some rules,
some of these students,
they don't want to be kicked out of
school and they might actually
behave better.
Well,
so I think you know this,
there's a lot of conversation right now
about some legislation even that's going
on about a disrupting speeches,
mandatory punishments for students who
do sell a certain number of times.
and I think that's actually less
important than I actually have somewhat
of a problem with the laws that create
mandatory punishments for vaguely
defined terms like disrupt,
which,
you know,
could be applied to pretty much anything
that a sneeze,
you know,
um,
but I think more important is when
administration is saying,
hey,
these are the values that really,
that this is the wellspring of
intellectual vitality,
that our institution relies on a,
these are the,
the ideals you should be paying
attention to.
This is what's going to make your
experience really worthwhile.
I think students will will listen to
that instead of maintaining the policies
that say thou shalt not say mean things
about your classmates that get students
in a very different mindset when they
come to college.
What are the statements are or what are
the principles that you add?
You guys want to see in those
statements.
The principles are largely,
this is a place of debate.
This is a place of intellectual
exploration.
It is not our job as administrators or
as faculty members to silence ideas that
we find controversial or protect you
from them.
It is our job.
It is our mission to expose you to ideas
that you might disagree with and give
you the tools that you need to analyze
them,
think critically about them,
formulate your own ideas and participate
in the conversation because that's what
you're going to have to do when you
leave after four or however many years
you're here,
that's part of life and our democracy is
participation.
If you don't participate,
then you know as the saying goes,
if you don't participate,
you have no grounds to complain.
We have to really get students in the
mindset that these are important life
skills and they're important to even in
other instances in the workplace.
That can be important if you have a
policy position,
If you're working at a company that you
think is either bad or one that you want
to promote,
you have to be able to think about the
people who disagree with you and what
they're going to say,
anticipate their response and formulate
an argument that resolves it.
You know,
there's countless situations in the
world,
outside of college were being able to
think critically is incredibly important
and really,
uh,
I think that you get a lot of value out
of doing that outside of the classroom
because it teaches you how to
contextualize the skill,
the teaches you how to apply it,
not just in the,
I read this assignment,
let's talk about it kind of way,
because that's really not how life works
once you graduate.
I wish it was.
It would make things a whole lot
simpler,
but you'd be out of a job probably.
That's true.
I would have to find something else to
do.
All right,
so we touched on the first amendment a
little bit in the first half,
but I think there's also just a
fundamental misunderstanding about what
speech is related to the first amendment
in that the first amendment basically is
about what the government is not allowed
to do and people have now extrapolated
that to think it means what everyone
can't do.
Can you talk to.
There's that famous xkcd comic about a
people have the right to tell you you're
an asshole on the internet and it
doesn't violate the first amendment.
and that's true.
Although I see it all day long,
I get,
I get that comic thrown at me sometimes
even when it's a government institution
doIng the censorship.
So it's,
it's overused a little bit too and that
kinda just gets in my craw a little bit,
but tHe first amendment really only Does
protect you from the government and it
doesn't just protect you from congress.
It protects you from the states.
It protects you from the municipalities
that protects you from the public
colleges and universities and their
administrators.
Uh,
those are all state actors for the first
amendment,
but it doesn't protect you against is
your private employer,
which means that I could well be fired
for anything I say on this show today.
See what I can do,
not to give you an ideas.
Uh,
you know,
your parents don't.
If you say I remember saying free speech
to my parents and I was very young
probably right after I read it about the
skokie case and my mother giving me a
side,
either burn a hole through my skull at
this point,
but you know,
it only protects you against the
government.
It doesn't protect you from criticism of
your peers and your contemporaries and
it shouldn't,
you know,
that's kind of part and parcel of having
the public conversation is if you have a
bad idea and you're out there spouting
it,
we all have the right to tell you you
got a shitty idea and we should say that
because otherwise,
well we might see that shitty idea is
spreading.
And,
and that's kind of the point of,
like we were talking aboUt earlier about
letting these terrible ideas out there
is so that we can stand up and defeat
them.
Yeah.
Are you seeing any major threats right
now from the government related to free
speech?
Because a lot of times I'll see people
saying,
well,
trump Is attacking this or he texts
journalism a lot now.
it's no secret what my feeling about the
mainstream media is these days.
I mean,
I think it's largely just partisan
garbage.
I don't think you should be killing
these people are harming these people in
any way.
Just to be very clear.
I hope that by by mocking them and
exposing their nonsense will get a new
generation of better journalists and
people who really live to the code of
trying to find truth and all of that.
But do you see a direct threat right now
coming from the government,
either from trump or or elsewhere?
There's always indirect threat yet.
I mean,
let's be clear.
People in power will always,
if given the opportunity,
silence their opponents,
they will preserve the status quo and
it's not just people in power.
It isn't entirely human reaction to want
to censor the people we disagree with.
We think we have terrible ideas.
That's kind of a baser instincts that we
all have now.
We have to overcome that and understand
the value of,
of not doing that,
but it's.
It's kind of understandable in a way and
that's why we have to be so vigilant in
protecting free speech because once the
tools are there,
they don't go away and we've seen this
throughout history and their wield it
and people laughed at me when I was
talking during the election cycle to I
guess kind of betrayed some of my
personal political.
Leif said,
you know,
I was kind of talking about how the
executive branch overreach as many
people did have the last administration
was problematic because you know,
what about the next guy comes to power?
Maybe he's going to do something crazy
and nobody.
They all laughed at me.
Hey,
I was talking about that.
I was talking about it when bush was
doing it,
I was talking about it when obama was
doing it and they laughed and then
donald j dot trump was elected president
and I looked at them and I said,
what now?
Uh,
and you know,
you,
you said,
oh,
it couldn't be possible that somebody we
disagree with all that much who we think
is really terrible,
whatever,
get elected president.
And when they started melting down over
the election,
I looked at them and I said,
told you so you can't be for if
executive actions when it's the guy you
like,
but then not for them when it's the guy
you don't like,
of course they're all going to do it if
you give them the power to do it.
And it's the same thing with free
speech.
and I think what's really important to
remember is that those mechanisms,
those tools with censorship are never
ever going to redound to the benefit of
the marginalized communities that people
are oftentimes seeking to protect.
It just doesn't happen.
The reason they are marginalized is that
they don't have political power.
They're not going to be the ones
implementing these rules and that's
incredibly problematic and people don't
understand that very practical reality
that those tools and censorship are
going to be used to defend the status
quo,
which is what these people are trying to
disrupt and disruption is kind of the
just the major threat that everyone in
power feels and it we've seen it
throughout history that they're in the
civil rights movement when protestors
were arrested for sitting at lunch
counters or for engaging in nonviolent
protests,
but were arrested for disorderly conduct
because people reacted to their protests
and violent ways because there were
violent vicodin,
thugs.
They were only exonerated Because of the
first amendment and it took going to the
supreme court and it's really important
to remember,
I mean,
how many lgbt artists and authors and
publications faced censorship and had
their materials deemed obscenity at
times and not even sent through the
mail,
you know,
sometImes before and preventing them
from integrating into the national
consciousness.
I mean,
it's,
it's really,
really important to.
Yeah.
So is there something happening right
now via the government that you think
shouldn't be happening?
I get the broad sense sort of blue sky
version of this that yes,
people in power always are gonna want to
maintain power and do what they have to
do to silence people,
etc.
But at the college and university level
specifically,
I think a lot of it is coming from the
department of justice and the office for
civil rights of the department of
education.
A few years back I had an agreement that
they called a blueprint for sexual
harassment policies at colleges and
universities and it basically defines
sexual harassment is any unwelcome
conduct of a sexual nature,
including verbal conduct,
which we also know as speech and the
breathtaking broadness of that policy
really kind of spread like wildfire.
And you know,
these harassment policies have always
been problematic at times.
This is directly tied to title nine,
right?
Yes.
And you know it's,
it's one of the.
I don't know if it's even an unintended
consequence.
It might be a very well unintended
consequence,
but you start seeing things.
I,
for example,
just the number of years back,
there was a student at the university of
Oregon who was sitting on the ledge in a
dorm room window and she saw a couple
outside and as a joke she shouted,
I hit it first,
which I didn't even know what that meant
when it first came into my head to look
it up and I realized that it was about
ray j,
uh,
having sex with kim kardashians and
kanye.
I guess that's the thing people care
about nowadays.
I don't know,
man.
Yeah,
he is the leader of speech movement.
Boy,
maybe I do need to find another job,
but anyways,
that the couple was offended and ran
upstairs and talk to the ra.
And this student was hit with several
disciplinary charges including sexual
harassment for just shouting.
I hit it first.
And this is because of the latitude that
these laws gave colleges to.
Well,
once,
you know,
department of education said,
this is what we consider sexual
harassment.
Well,
no college in university administrator
in the right mind is going to look at
that and say,
oh,
we'll just ignore that.
They're going to write new policies
because they don't want huge
investigations that costs a lot of
money,
take a lot of time,
and have ultimately the potential to
cost the school all of its federal
funding when it comes down to it.
So we've seen the proliferation of these
really broad policies,
some of which have hilarious lists of
examples of things that could constitute
sexual harassment,
like inappropriately directed laughter,
elevator eyes is another fire fame for
it.
These are all things that are known as
flirting recording or whatever you call
it,
term,
but like that's how you meet people and
sometimes it,
it really is.
And,
and,
and honestly it's the sexual harassment
angle has become a broader
discriminatory harassment angle because
a lot of these policies start to look
the same based on any protected class.
And so when you say that,
you know,
any unwelcome comments based on a
protected class,
uh,
you know,
the not drawing from a particular policy
or anything is harassed.
Discriminatory harassment.
Well that's a big problem because that
cuts off subjectively whichever way you
go.
Basically half of a,
a debate.
People,
for instance,
on different sides of affirmative action
are both going to find their opponents
ideology probably offensive.
Of course,
if you are against affirmative action
for whatever reason,
you might be a people who support
affirmative action,
they're gonna say,
well,
that is discriminatory based on a
protected class race and they shouldn't
be allowed to say that.
We've seen students hosting events like
affirmative action bake sales to kind of
make a point about what they think is
the unfairness and affirmative action
and administrators have tried to shut
them down and sometimes succeeded and
shutting them down and I can give you
countless examples of things just like
that,
but it's.
It's dangerous because it kind of
creates an orthodoxy of what we're
allowed to say,
what we're allowed to think and you
know,
there is no position in that.
I can think of that I'm and I can say
actually I think there is no position
that shouldn't be subject to challenge.
There is nothing that shouldn't be
susceptible to somebody disagreeing with
it in a public way and starting that
conversation.
Nobody has the right to declare this is
how it is.
That is,
I guess our collective to circle back to
the beginning.
It's our collective right to participate
in that decision of what we believe.
Yeah,
and that's why I have
problem with this related to the way
that the modern left fuels with these
things because if you're going to say,
all right,
we're not going to draw cartoons about
certain things.
Now I'm not saying you should go out of
your way to offend people,
but once you say we're going to allow
certain things not to be done,
you've handed all of your faculty,
all of your power,
all of your decision making capability
over to a certain set of people.
It doesn't matter what those,
what those people believe in or are.
But then it's like,
well then they know,
well,
we got them with something.
We can just keep going and going and
going and before you know it,
you know it's too late to,
to fight back.
I mean,
and again it's going to backfire.
It's going to backfire against the
people and,
and I,
I think that you see it backfiring
sometimes.
You look at the faculty members recently
who have been targeted by outrage mobs
of people calling for their heads or
their jobs or sometimes both.
Sometimes when by the way,
and my good friend bret weinstein,
it still does not have a job just
recently for more straightening example
even is a fresno state random gerard
treated some intemperate and not
particularly polite things about Barbara
Bush right after she died.
Um,
and you're being very kind and she can
do whatever she wants.
But yeah,
it was pretty nasty stuff.
My mother told me never to speak ill of
the dead sea.
I,
it,
I really know.
I mean you were being nice to,
to what was tweeted feelings here and it
was the right that was calling for her
head and I mean,
one of my colleagues,
I felt really bad.
I was the one who helped write the
letter,
but he was the one who wrote our public
facing blog post done on the website.
He was getting hate mail and probably
still is getting hate mail from people
saying,
how could you defend this woman?
How could you.
I mean,
it goes both ways.
Everyone's going to sense try and censor
their opponent,
so just really be careful.
Right.
Well,
I'm glad you brought that one up.
So basically this,
this woman who's,
she's a professor,
she tweeted some really nasty stuff
about Barbara Bush who had just died and
by,
by every account,
Barbara Bush was a totally decent woman,
but that's actually irrelevant for this.
And yes.
Then the right started screaming and oh,
she should be fired.
She should be fired.
She was not fired.
The fresno state.
She's still there.
Um,
I thought,
wow,
this is an exact example of how free
speech is supposed to work.
She said what she wanted people mocked
her or supported her.
The university decided to make a
decision.
Now it's interesting.
If the university had fired her,
let's say they had said these ideas are
beyond the pale.
And then people started digging into
some other things that she's said that
are,
that are pretty radical.
If,
if that had happened where you guys have
offered her defense because doesn't the
university have the right to make the
decisions that it wants?
I don't know what their policies are on
tenure,
for example,
or that sort of thing,
but don't they have the right to employ
people that they want to be employed or
not?
Not that I want to give that power to
the mob because we know that the mob
does awful things.
It depends when the government as an
employer,
the government actually is restricted in
what it can do.
A for a,
an with respect respect to an employee's
off duty speech when a,
and I think that's particularly
important with faculty members who are
supposed to be public intellectuals.
They're supposed to be out there kind of
discussing and debating this is what we
expect out of faculty members at
colleges and universities,
but when the government is the employer
and the speeches made as a private
citizen on a matter of public concern is
this very clearly was then the
government has to make a pretty high
showing that that speech so materially
interferes with the provision of
services that the government is involved
in,
that it warrants overcoming the employer
employees first amendment rights.
Uh,
and we actually wrote a long letter and
lose co-sign sign by the aclu of
northern California,
uh,
electronic frontier foundation and a
whole bunch of other,
uh,
organizations and on [inaudible] behalf
and sent it.
And incidentally,
shortly after they got our letter,
the university issued their statement
that they weren't going to discipline
her.
Right?
So,
so you are making the distinction in
this case that because this was not on
campus,
this wasn't being in a class taught in
the class or,
or brainwashing students in the
classroom,
that's different what she's doing on her
private side.
And especially because as you said,
as a public intellectual,
you're supposed to be talking about
stuff that that's different than perhaps
if she had said these very same things
in class,
they could have taken a different stance
that maybe would have had a little more
legal positioning.
Is that fair to say?
That's where it gets tricky because
there's a circuit split.
Get the supreme court back in 2006,
held that speech made pursuant to
official job duties is basically speech
that's commissioned by the government
and therefore it does not have first
amendment protection and you can be
fired for it,
but they did not decide whether or not
that would relate to speech that relates
to scholarship or teaching as a supreme
court put it,
which is due to the special concern
about academic freedom that we have for
the reasons of faculty members being
public intellectuals.
The fourth circuit and the ninth circuit
where California is.
Have both said that no,
this ruling,
that speech pursuant to official job
duties does not apply at colleges and
universities to speech that relates to
scholarship or teaching.
So in California she could have been
protected either way,
but it's not that way all around the
country.
Some courts have declined to find that
exception to the 2006 garcia ruling.
Others have kind of ignored it for the
time being.
So one of these days the supreme court
is probably going to have to make
another decision on that.
I'm curious.
I know you guys are a nonpartisan
organization,
but if these decisions were left up to
the states,
do you guys have a position on that in
and of itself?
I'm sure you have a personal position,
but does fire have a position on that?
I mean I,
I think our,
our position is that the exception for
scholarship or teaching absolutely
should be applied across the country.
It's really fundamentally important for
faculty members to be able to conduct,
you know,
controversial,
disruptive,
you know,
as it relates to the status quo,
research and writing without fearing for
their jobs because that's how we're
going to get new ideas.
If you just talk about things that
aren't going to rock the boat,
if you just researched things that
we're never going to get anywhere.
You need the bomb throwers.
There's room for that.
So what about cases where,
and I guess this brings up a little bit
related to tenure because I think there
is something interesting because it's,
it's funny,
I hear from professors,
I get a ton of email from professors
saying that they,
they love what we're doing here and that
they're afraid sometimes tenured
professors are still afraid of the mob,
they know they're not going to get
fired,
but they'Re afraid of the mob.
Is there an inherent problem in tenure
in a way now because you could,
if you have that protection,
and I'm all for saying whatever you want
to say that technically if you were a
history history professor,
let's say you could start,
you could just start losing your mind
and teaching really dishonest,
complete reversal of the truth stuff.
Um,
and have the protection of not being
fired like that actually handicaps the
pursuit of knowledge from,
from the university,
doesn't it?
I'm not terribly concerned about that
because generally speaking,
there are ways for faculty to be
disciplined or removed even with tenure.
Oftentimes for gross professional
competency issues.
Um,
you know,
if you are say teaching math and you're
teaching students that two plus two is
17.
I think that the common core you can,
there's ways that the university can
address that and that's not really what
we're seeing.
What we're seeing more often is a,
for instance,
the professor who's teaching physics who
is on the side of the holocaust denier a
and he's,
you know,
maybe not necessarily teaching that in
class,
but does that have any ramifications for
his ability to teach physics?
Probably not.
That's not a competency competency to
teach the topic that you were hired to
teach thing.
Right.
But if it leaked into the classroom then
that then it's a separate issue.
That's.
Well,
if you are teaching a class on physics
and find some occasion to talk about the
holocaust,
I think you're probably not teaching the
thing that you were hired and then it's
up to the school to decide what to do.
That's it.
It's a different problem I think.
I think that that indicates pretty
squarely along with the denial of the
holocaust happened that you are in fact
losing your right.
So what are some of the cases and maybe
one or two cases that you guys are
working on right now or that you have
your eye on right now that you think are
particularly relevant that people should
know about?
Well,
we just,
uh,
issued a press release this morning.
In fact,
uh,
just a mere hour or two before I came
here,
uh,
at syracuse university where we sent a
letter on friday.
Uh,
this one is just bAnanas.
Yeah.
Let me pause you for a second.
I haven't read it yet,
but I wanted to go to syracuse to be in
broadcasting because I wanted it to be
like a news anchor or a or a sports
center.
Anchors road.
I really want it to be.
But there are big broadcasting school,
so I'm already fascinated by this as a
place that's,
you know,
about disseminating information or you
might be glad you didn't hear this.
Here we go.
a fraternity had an event every year
where the pledges or new members would
come in.
It was a private event and they would do
skits that roasted the other members of
the fraternity.
A lot of fraternities have this kind of
tradition,
I'm pretty sure that mine did,
but they went through some skits and one
of them,
for example,
was making fun of a member of the
fraternity who was unknown and vocal,
trump supporter and conservative.
So they satirized him by having somebody
who was supposed to be him starting a
rival fraternity that was quote unquote
a white empire.
And to join people had to take a
horrifically racist,
antisemitic oath so far.
Sounds like it's all in good fun.
Well,
whatever it may be tasteless,
but all good friends over and you know
what the satirizing any.
It's no different than you see comedians
doing all the time on a stage.
you're satirizing people.
Yeah.
Uh,
another one was,
uh,
they satirized one of their brothers for
being chronically whipped by his
girlfriend and portrayed him as a
mentally retarded and we had him in a
wheelchair and all that stuff.
And this was all on a private event.
And you hear the laughter in the
audience indicated that nobody was
really offended by it.
They understood this is kinda just
poking fun at people.
The problem is that videos of it leaked
in the student newspaper,
published them,
which you know,
they had the right to do as well.
It can't be grudged than that,
and of course,
as you might imagine,
outrage erupted and the within a matter
of days,
the fraternity had been expelled
permanently from campus.
18 students have been charged with
disciplinary conduct or discipline,
disciplinary code violations,
and they're being threatened with
suspension or expulsion and this is like
all right,
before finals,
and meanwhile a adjunct faculty member
had the gall to express concern about
how the university was handling all of
this and they immediately told them
because your views don't align with
ours,
you are no longer qualified to teach at
syracuse university.
Unbelievable.
And it's incredibly author authoritarian
sounding.
I mean,
they are,
they're just willing to steamroll over
anybody who gets in their way in pursuit
of really just giving somebody a head on
a pike so that the crowd is mollified,
you know,
it's nuts.
They've charged them with a sexual
harassment,
discriminatory harassment.
Uh,
nevermind the fact that nobody who the
speech was actually intended for
actually was offended by it.
It didn't really,
it's not their fault,
you know,
they don't know how the videos lead,
they're posting to a private facebook
page and somebody must've had access to
somebody's computer or something like
that,
but the speech was purely private and
nobody was offended by it.
And if every conversation between two
students can be the grounds for a
disciplinary investigation because a
third party later found out what was
said during that conversation.
Well,
we don't be in jail.
Exactly.
It reduces free speech to a complete
melody.
It's crazy.
Uh,
and you know,
it's just,
it's really,
it's galling and the,
just really a harsh and punitive bent of
the,
of the university and all of this is,
is mystifying.
Wait,
so just on the technical side now
because this is something good that
trump's done related to this because he
got rid of a lot of the title nine
expansions and all that and devoss and
they got rid of that stuff,
which I assume you agree with.
Right?
Basically,
I mean,
it's stuff that we'd spent a lot of time
fighting against.
Okay.
So obama expanded it.
Trump got rid of it.
I think for the name and the name of
free speech,
when you hear stories of like laura
kipnis,
who I've had on and,
and many others,
the witch hunts that happen that are
crazy.
So these policies that they are saying
that these students violated,
these have nothing to do with government
policies,
right?
These,
they're saying they violated school
policies,
is that correct?
They're discriminatory harassment
policies are obviously drawn on a lot of
the same language because they receive
federal money in the form of student
loans and things like that.
So they actually still have to adhere to
title nine even though they're not a
state institution obviously,
but you know,
they been charged with this laundry list
of offenses.
Uh,
they've,
the administration has been rushing
through,
trying to kind of get the process over
with as soon as possible.
Meanwhile,
not giving them really a lot of details
until just recently in terms of,
you know,
what the charges are based on,
in all of this.
I mean,
it's very clearly a steam rolling and,
uh,
it's,
it's outrageous.
Uh,
and you know,
that's kind of the most recent thing.
So tell me a little bit about how you
guys get involved in that.
So okay,
so you issue a press statement now or a
press release now they know they have a
little bit of public defense.
Do you guys actually work with the
students,
like just kind of lay out how that whole
process goes?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
on our website we have a format anyone
can fill out to request help and me and
my team every morning we will go through
the case submissions and uh,
we'll review them and follow up for more
documentation if necessary.
And like I said,
we get damn near close to a thousand of
them a year now,
uh,
which is a whole lot of work.
And we investigate and develop the cases
and figure out what the best situ,
you know,
the best possible tactics in each case
would be a.
Usually the next step involves writing a
letter telling the university which in
syracuse case we sent that on friday,
telling them,
hey,
this is the applicable law,
are these applicable norms that you
should be adhering to as though college,
um,
and here's why what you're doing has run
a foul of all of that.
Generally speaking,
you know,
we'll wait for a response in good faith
given university some time to
acknowledge our concerns and work
through them and,
you know,
otherwise we will,
excuse me,
issue a press release and start bringing
public pressure to bear sometimes in
public college and university cases.
We'll take it to litigation if we have
to.
Not every case obviously because you
know,
there's a range of cases that are,
you know,
make for a good lawsuit.
But even just recently filed a lawsuit
at joliet junior college and this is
kind of,
again,
kind of flips the narrative a little bit
because there was a students who saw a
people,
uh,
basically talking about how capitalism
is great and decided that she wanted to
make a good point about socialism.
So she handed out and flyers about how,
you know,
it said shut down capitalism,
inviting people to like a workshop,
a about socialism.
This was actually not far from where I
live in chicago,
joliet junior college,
and she was actually confronted by a
number of campus police officers who
pulled her to an interrogation room,
demanded to examine the flyers and then
confiscated them and saying,
you can't do that here.
You know,
the,
the political climate right now is,
you know,
might start something.
I'm actually shocked to hear it
happening that that story is not the
reverse.
If this is an odd one,
I'm glad you used it as an example.
Actually,
you know,
it goes to show.
I actually,
you know,
you'll be interested to hear this.
I,
my,
my team and I actually did a really a
quick analysis,
and this isn't scientific or anything of
all the public cases that we've had on
our website from the beginning of fires
history and actually more than half of
them have nothing to do with politics.
More than half of them are simply
administrators having power again.
And when they have the power,
they will use it to regulate or silence
speech that they find inconvenient or
critical of the university or
administrators or,
or just kind of not nice,
generally less than half of our cases
had to do with speakers being silenced
specifically because of the viewpoint
that we're espousing on a political
level.
It's,
you know,
it kind of undoes a lot of the
narrative.
And to be honest,
I'm kind of a little bit tired of the
whole,
whether the right or left love
censorship,
more argument.
I think it's completely unproductive and
does nothing to solve the problem,
which is we all need to understand why
protecting free speech is important.
I'd mUch rather focus my time there.
Um,
and you know,
so it's really that that whole narrative
can,
could use a little deconstructing for a
little bit.
And I'm glad that we had that case that
kind of allowed us to,
to show it and people appreciate it.
I got a lot of messages from people on
the right who said,
you know,
I disagree with everything that that
young woman had to say.
And I would sit there and now and yelled
at in her face,
but you know what,
I'm damn glad you guys stood up for her
rights.
and you know,
when I get messages like that,
it just,
it warms my heart and I get them from
people on both sides saying,
you know what,
I probably wouldn't have reacted in the
same way you did leaping to a defense of
free speech.
But I'm glad you did it because I got
something out of that.
Uh,
you know,
it made me think about why my reaction
wasn't that,
uh,
and if I,
if I get,
if I can elicit that in people,
I feel great about my day.
That's the heavy lifting,
I think.
Well,
that's a beautiful thing and that's why
I did what you guys are doing.
A,
the thing I want to mention is that I
just remembered in this last moment that
the reason that you're here,
I,
so I had wanted to have one of you guys
on for about a year or so,
and you've been on our,
our master list of all this.
And then I think about three months or
so ago,
someone tweeted at me that they were at
school at school library and they were
watching a video of me and ben shapiro
and that they were reported to the,
either the diversity office or one of
these things that it was hate speech and
that another student shouldn't be
allowed to watch these,
these evil things,
etc.
Etc.
It turns out that this was in the uk,
so it was not under the jurisdiction
that you guys a cover,
which obviously is the United States.
Um,
but it just shows that this thing,
this monster that we're fighting is not
local to us here in America.
It's all over the world.
And there are other organizations like
fire that do this work.
And uh,
yeah.
And although it's depressing to know
that somebody is being reported for
watching a video that I put out there,
it's good to know that you guys all came
to the rush.
You all came to the defense and you were
like,
who is it?
Can we connect with them?
You know,
I connected them with some of your
people,
I think.
And maybe you've passed them on to them
with spikes over there.
Yeah,
it is.
And you know,
you see it happening in Canada all the
time in the uk.
I mean,
you can,
I have google alerts set and every.
No,
I wouldn't say every morning because
it's more like 40,000
times a day.
I get emails from google with the latest
headlines about free speech and it's not
just even the uk and Canada.
There are students protesting in India
about freedom of speech issues and all
kinds of countries.
Australia,
it's a big conversation right now.
This is,
you know,
this is not limited to here.
It's not limited to anywhere.
This,
the idea that college campuses are kind
of a,
both a microcosm of society and a,
a training ground and an eye,
a place where the ideas of the country,
uh,
kind of come from in a large sense.
That's a kind of a global,
a concept.
I don't think that's limited to higher
education in the United States.
And you know,
it's,
I really hope that we can convince
students that's where it's safeguarding.
Uh,
it's,
it's too important not to rel.
Said my friend,
I'm with ya,
and for more on the fine work that ari
and the fire folks are doing,
checkout the fire.org.